bueno realmente esto es muy importante
de cara a lo que serán los próximos dos
meses y ya la posesión en el mes de
enero porque básicamente el que un
oficial de alto rango que representa a
la diplomacia de los eeuu como es pompeo
asegurará que impugnar las elecciones
que pugnar estos resultados es
completamente válido y que calificar a
los votos como votos legales y también
asegurará que tiene que proteger la
constitución y que el presidente hará lo
que sea para defenderla si realmente
llama la atención sobre todo al saber él
fue cuestionado por periodistas sobre
qué tipo de instrucciones realmente está
dando a diplomáticos y oficiales que
están en otros países de los eeuu cuando
se supone que el departamento de estado
debe ser independiente del gobierno o el
partido que esté básicamente en turno
también llama la atención que el
presidente ha cambiado recientemente
otros oficiales al interior del
pentágono al igual que este apoyo de
mitch mcconnell y está también en juego
al interior del senado precisamente por
esto se ha dado este apoyo de makoun a
varias sillas todavía que están
pendientes del conteo de votos
será fundamental para que cuando el
presidente electo joe biden llegue a la
casa blanca sepáis exactamente con
cuántas sillas republicanas tendrá que
digamos de negociar al interior del
senado ahora diana uno de los temas que
también preocupan en esta transición de
poder es el tema presupuestario que
sabemos sobre los fondos que están
congelados para que bailen pueda llevar
a cabo su empalme político
bueno lo que se sabe recientemente es
que la oficina del presupuesto de la
casa blanca dio la instrucción a las
oficinas federales que comiencen a
trabajar en el presupuesto fiscal para
el año entrante esto teniendo en cuenta
que el presupuesto se debe presentar en
el mes de febrero y que el presidente
electo joe biden llegaría a la casa
blanca antes del 30 de enero y que
donaldson tendría que salir del
ejercicio del poder así que esto también
llama la atención porque se está viendo
que el presidente está intentando no
solamente colocar obstáculos de tipo
legal para hacer esta transición sino de
tipo financiero que no van a permitir
ayudar en poder hacer una transición
tranquila por lo menos llamarlo de esa
manera también se sabe que la primera
dama no ha hablado con la esposa del
presidente electo joe biden para
comenzar a trabajar también en esta
transición diana gracias por la
información diana castañeda corresponsal
de france 24 en la capital
estadounidense